Joining me today is the Democratic
nominee for Senate from the Great State
of Utah.
Jenny Wilson.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Well,
thank you.
It's great to be here.
I am glad to have you here.
I was reading your bio and it said that
you were a fifth generation,
Utah u t a h n.
There you go.
I didn't know it was spelled that way.
I wasn't sure it was even pronounced
that way,
but I did it right.
You did write down.
Don't throw the Aan.
What would that even though you're not a
Utah?
Well that's why I thought
Utah or something.
But you are a fifth generation use.
I said to you right before we started,
I've actually never been to Utah,
so I only know the things of Utah that
sort of get out there
like John Stockton,
Karl Malone,
the jazz,
the aren't doing well right now,
but that's a moment of this.
Yeah,
but you know,
for all the world's best skiing,
incredible snow,
beautiful mountains.
I leave my front door and in eight
minutes I'm in remote wilderness on a
run or hike or with my dog.
It's really great.
Great State.
So tell me,
we're going to talk a little bit about
Utah generally,
but tell me just a little bit about your
family and upbringing.
FIFTH-GENERATION UTAH.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
my ancestors go back to the first person
to even make it into the valley ahead of
Brigham Young.
He was a scout for Brigham young snakes
at Orson Pratt and he was head of the
pioneer trail and I looked into the
valley and said,
this is the place even before officially
Brigham Young said this is the place.
So he had actually started planting and
irrigating before Brigham young and the
rest of them came in.
Yeah.
And tell me just a little bit about your
upbringing and family and that's it.
Yeah.
So I,
uh,
kind of fell into politics,
not by choice.
My Dad was the mayor of Salt Lake City
in the seventies and eighties and I was
a kid of the mayor that would go with
them around town and to visit the banker
and you know,
the local religious leader,
whomever.
And I guess I have the five kids.
I ended up being the one that stuck with
this affliction affliction,
so like for a kid,
I mean I know it's just as you as a kid,
it's just your life,
but as a child of a,
well my dad was a people person still is
and I think that helped a bed.
It's a busy life to have a parent who's
running and on the ballot and I think my
kids are now living that with me and
there's a little bit of,
I think stress with that because it's
not a typical life,
but it's a good one.
I feel really lucky to have had that
experience and got to know the
community.
My Mom's a small business owner and
artists and gallery owner,
so I was able to kind of go to her
business too as a kid growing up and was
really a great life.
Yeah.
And we were,
we were talking right before,
you've had a bunch of jobs,
also politics that have sort of led you
to this.
Can you give me,
give me a couple of those that you've,
you've bounced around,
you've done some stuff.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you know,
back to the day that my dad was running
was always thrown into the campaign and
then in 1988 he ran for governor and
that was my first real job and they
actually paid me.
I was the press secretary.
So I thought,
wow,
I can make a living doing this.
And it sort of helped in 1988 a define
my politics a little,
I think some of the relationships I had
on that campaign.
And then I ended up
a little bit about that.
Like what were some of the four major
formative?
Yeah,
I think,
um,
well Utah's a very homogenous state.
So I think we were the Democrats,
right?
So we were sort of the calendar to what
was out there.
And so I think,
uh,
environmental preservation,
a balancing government is important I
think.
And that was one of the principles of
that campaign.
And uh,
so anyway,
I just kind of fell into it.
Ended up on Capitol Hill.
I worked initially for a congressman
from Oregon,
less a coin and 90.
And then in [inaudible] 92,
he was running for the US Senate.
I joined that race in Oregon.
He was defeated and I ended up working
after that for Congressman from Utah,
uh,
initially as press secretary and then I
became his chief of staff.
His name is Bill Orton and unfortunately
he was a blue dog,
Democrat,
democrat.
Yeah.
What does happen
been to the old school of Democrats
because obviously we're going to talk
about your politics and I did a little
digging here and I think there,
there's some stuff.
There's some points of agreement that we
have for sure.
What I wish out of the Democrats is that
the old school Democrats still existed.
What I've seen consistently is that as
the progressives have gone further left,
and I would say it's really out there
now.
They've sort of taken the whole party in
any of the moderates are the blue dogs
or whatever you want to call that wing.
I don't know.
They're either silent or they're gone
altogether.
Do you think that's a fair estimation
or,
or how would you even define some of
these things?
Like a blue dog,
Democrat versus progressive?
Wow.
What a.
In the nineties,
my memories of Bill Orton and
unfortunately he passed away a few years
ago,
but I'm used to pretty young a
congressman in the day and I worked with
him for about four years and he was on
the budget committee and the Banking
Committee and very concerned about the
deficit.
So that had a great impression on me.
I learned a lot about title might reform
about discretionary spending,
about our choices and I do think that as
we see the deficit and the debt go up an
APP,
um,
and it,
you know,
their deficit as you know,
is tied to economic prosperity.
When we do well,
our deficits are not as high.
Our overall debt keeps increasing.
So I really feel that we need to get
back to some discipline and I think that
that has been missed,
uh,
in recent years.
And I work on a Salt Lake County
Council.
I'm an elected now and we do balance the
budget every year and it's much tougher
in years where we have economic decline
and those are the years we can't,
um,
do maybe some of the nice to haves.
So I think we need to get back to more
of a fluid budget process where congress
recognize,
recognizes,
hey,
this isn't such a good year,
can we find a different way of budgeting
so that we don't always give away things
that we can afford?
Is that possible
perhaps at the local level,
state level,
city level,
etc.
And just not possible anymore on the
federal level because when you sit,
talk about fiscal responsibility,
that sounds so foreign to me as a
democrat,
but by the way,
the republicans are horrible attitude
and you know,
look at the,
the,
uh,
the omni bus that was just passed and
all that.
So I'm not even defending Any of them.
They have some of the principles that
should make sense.
And so in a way they deserve more
criticism because it's part of their
package where it's a little less.
So for democrat,
well I think the division in Washington
is forced budget reconciliation rather
than true budgets.
And how can you reprioritize when you
are just on the fly saying,
hey,
another two weeks,
let's go two more days.
So let's come back next week and fix
this.
So that's my concern is that we're at
the point with so much division that
we're not having real conversations and
I do think there's a baseline budget if
we were to go maybe even to a two year
budget cycle,
we're really find a way to force
congress into actually true debate about
what are our priorities because we all
are frustrated with the federal
government.
It's not serving us,
it's not serving us at the local level.
And you know,
I'm not someone who wouldn't say that we
need to spend.
I think we do need to invest in our
communities and there's so many things
that the federal government can do to
support us at the local level and
should.
but when it's just rubber stamping what
was done the year before,
I'm at last minute.
It's chaotic and it's not efficient.
Yeah.
What do you think is the right amount of
power for the federal government to have
over the states?
A lot of my audience that leans a little
more libertarian or classical liberal or
conservative,
whatever it is.
This is one of the key issues for them
that we have to get this stuff back to
the local municipalities and I'm pretty
much,
yeah,
I mean I feel really good about the role
that,
uh,
I have at the local level.
I do think that there are certain things
that I'm really matter to us as a nation
that we have to have in place.
One,
of course being defense,
our interstate system and our highways
and our connectivity and commerce.
There's so many things that if we were
to be isolationists state to state
really jeopardize our,
our ability to act as a super power,
the one that we are to be really.
I think I'm the best of our nation,
but there are a lot of things that we
should do locally.
I mean,
I worry a little about too much,
um,
diversion when you look at education.
Um,
I don't want there to be a decision that
we would go four days a week in one
state and not have basic standards.
So I think a basic level of standards.
But then let states decide.
I mean,
we've got California here being very
different than Utah,
very different than,
you know,
a southern state or New York.
So I'm basically there on that.
To me,
I always say,
no,
I would want to kick all of education
back to the states.
But then people ask have totally legit
question,
which I think is what you're saying.
Well,
what if states start really doing very
drastically different things?
What I would say is that maximum
freedom,
the ability to leave a state you don't
like if you don't like what they're
doing.
I think that that's the better answer.
But I guess getting some,
some baseline I think is a is a sound
or.
Absolutely.
And I do think though,
we look at the unique character of each
of our states and we need to foster that
and find a way to,
you know,
really enable a state to do well on its
own.
Uh,
and you know,
we could start over would do it
differently,
wouldn't we?
But we have to understand that in 2018
there are certain things that are in
place that,
um,
you know,
the conversation needs to be,
how do we reform,
maybe not dismantle.
I don't know if we would do it
differently if we starteD over.
I wish we would get back to some of that
stuff.
I would do many things differently if we
start over here.
Like what Virginia.
Well,
like I think there is a better way to
fund medicaid and medicare and some of
our big programs.
I do believe as a democrat and I believe
strongly and fairness and compassion and
the government being a tool that we can
and should invest.
It's just,
I think we've ended up building year
after year after year on something that
was created maybe for a good purpose at
one point in time,
but is not as efficient as it needs to
be.
And I'm,
I consider myself a reformer.
that's one of the reasons I like what I
do is I have the opportunity to step in
and look at how to make something better
and try and figure out a way to enact
change.
View worry as someone that you're saying
you're pretty content with the work that
you're doing now and you've been able to
say,
no,
we can't do this if we can't budget it
and it all kind of make sense and you
let the chips fall wheRe they may that
you could end up going to the swamp
where it seems like nothing changes and
that it doesn't sell that fun to me to
be.
There might be,
you know,
it's nice to maybe be on the national
stage and play with more high rollers
and that kind of thing,
but that you lose the real sort of
ability to,
to govern the way you would want it.
It's a good point.
I really believed the senate can change,
can change and that change will make a
big difference.
I'd like to get back to the days where
orrin hatch for my state and ted kennedy
work together and solve problems and we
were seeing too much polarization.
We don't have enough conversation on my
council.
We have five republicans,
four democrats and we worked together
and I know that I have to go find that
first vote right.
I'm not a mathematician,
it's,
yeah,
the collegiality matters and listening
and trying and compromise.
What's the tenor of politics in Utah
right now is what's going on nationally
with just this endless craziness.
Is that happening to you guys at the
local level?
We tend to be a to five to 10 points.
Uh,
the,
the president's numbers and profile and
polling tends to be about 10 percent
higher in favor in Utah.
So we still have a lot of people who
were pro trump.
I'm the core downtown salt lake,
which is our kind of more progressive
area.
you're going to say the reverse of that
and our urban areas,
probably 50 slash 50,
so we're like a lot of states where you
have a very progressive kind of core
city and suburban area 50 slash 50,
and then you get to very conservative
area.
So as a state that generally runs red,
um,
and that leans more conservative for
sure.
As someone that's running as a democrat,
what's,
what's the primary process like first as
a democrat?
Like what kind of people are you
reading?
Where are you wearing?
Well,
interestingly,
um,
two years ago there was a very much a
strong bernie sanders presence in our
state because,
you know,
the lds church has a lot of dominance.
there are a lot of people who speak out
forcefully against the one party system,
which is generally what we have in the
state.
And so you get some pretty progressive
people.
And we were an 80 slash 20.
I'm bernie sanders state to hillary
clinton.
Yeah.
Which is kind of surprising.
But um,
things have sort of calmed down.
I would expect that just because of the
nature of a democrat at that point
because the state liens so far.
The other way that if you're going to
say you're a democrat,
you may as well go all in on that.
Generally,
I think so.
And we alsO,
like every state,
we have our own nomination process and
the republicans have a closed a
republican system,
so you have to affiliate with the
republican with an r on the voter file.
And so therefore there are actually are
a lot of independence who are actually
filing as republicans because they want
to vote that way.
And with that party,
what's your policy on that?
For the open or closed prison?
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't know.
We've debated it on the democratic side
and because the democrats are few and
far between in my state we register at
20,
25 percent,
but we do pull independence as I
mentioned.
Um,
you know,
we're not in the driver's seat and some
of those policies,
so we just sort of work with whatever
makes sense because we're not in the one
able to do anything.
But that always strikes me as one of
those things where it's like the closed
primary does make sense to me because
that's to nominate who you want out of
that party.
And if you just have an open primary,
well you could get all sorts of people
who will never vote for any of those
candidates purposely getting into help
candidates that they think are going to
be more handicapped ultimately.
So I don't have.
I know a lot of people think that the
closed primary thing is somehow a
conspiracy or anti democratic or
something.
But I don't have a problem with.
The problem is what do you do with
independence because most people tend to
affiliate independent.
I mean people I know,
I mean there are people like you and me
and,
and elected or in meeting or whatever
that tend to be the insiders who
obviously follow this and get very
deeply entrenched and every step of the
way.
And uh,
I think most utahns are sort of in the
middle and uh,
so I don't know,
that gets a little confusing because if
we close,
both them weren't as an independent
government.
IndependenT does nothing.
Or you can see the independents can vote
in either,
but then why wouldn't anyone voted
register as a,
as an independent,
right.
I guess there's no easy answer on that
one.
Yeah.
Our big battle in the republican party
right now is whether or not we're going
to do away with the caucus system and go
to the conventions rather and go to a
direct primary.
So that's our battle right now.
We have a two tiered system you can pick
either now and that's under review.
What are some of the other issues?
Is there anything else in Utah that you
just see as like,
just like the technical stuff,
the technical problems related to voting
or districting gerrymandering,
that sort of thing,
but someone that's on the other side,
gerrymander,
it's a very big problem.
And then we have wacky maps like a lot
of states.
Um,
there's a ballot initiative,
so share one is a,
um,
redistricting commission ballot
initiative that should likely passed.
They got the required signatures to get
on.
It seemed so,
um,
that would require that the legislature
listened to a redistricting commission
that makes the recommendation,
but the decision does lie in the hands
of the legislature in our state.
Right.
So whAt are some of the other democratic
principles,
layout,
some democratic good old democratic
principles in you nash?
I mean,
just personally for me,
some of the things that you believe in.
I've affiliated with the democratic
party because I think that the party has
been the party.
The one has battled for fairness and
compassion over the years.
I mean,
I have been pro lgbtq rights from day
one.
I was the first time I council to move
forward,
um,
local policies we did even before my
election to the county council years
ago,
four years ago,
um,
housing nondiscrimination,
but we didn't have medical fairness in
terms of our,
um,
health care plans at salt lake county.
So when I was first elected in 2004,
I moved that and I couldn't get a
republican vote.
so it took several takes trying to
redefine the benefits and ultimately we
ended up passing it six three with a
republican supporting us.
So,
uh,
I think issues like that have been key.
I think we have a very.
One of the reasons I think I'm so active
in politics in my state is that we don't
have balance,
uh,
back in my dad's era in the seventies,
we did have a republican governor.
We had a democratic governor rather.
Uh,
it's been since the seventies since we
had a democrat in the us senate from the
state of Utah.
And that's the person that orrin hatch
defeated.
So I really believe that good government
is a balanced government and we live it
and see it on my county council again
with that,
can I have five,
four?
We have a democratic county executive,
we call it a mayor and so we're,
I feel like we're in a really good
position in my day job now to bring
about fairness and balance,
but we're 80 slash 20 and our
legislature,
we are republican governor and so on
down.
So part of what I fight for is balance.
I think it makes sense for good
government.
It's interesting too to stake out
positions that,
you know are not the popular ones there
too,
just so that the system doesn't become
too corroded or,
or too stiff.
But what about.
So it sounds sort of like you're,
you're socially liberal and fiscally
conservative.
BaSic.
I would agree with that.
I think.
So.
Where were you at on abortion?
I'm pro choice.
Um,
I believe that that women should have
that right to choose.
One of the reasons I really,
the more I've learneD about younger
women,
um,
you know,
my own years with friends growing up,
I see at times women who don't have the
security that I've had my entire life
with good parents and support are often,
um,
pray to being victimized.
And so I think that a woman's right to
choose is very much critical because of
that.
And I know that,
um,
you know,
in a very conservative state,
I've had situations to support my sister
who carried her child,
I've been friends with.
People have made different decisions and
I just fundamentally believe that women
need to be in the driver's seat on that
decision and we can't go back to the
days of real,
real tragedies.
Um,
prior to roe versus wade.
Do you see a cutoff point on it or were
you on that?
Um,
well,
I think that that's a decision for
science and I think the courts have
landed through roe versus Wade.
And so I,
that's the best I can do,
but follow what we have in place now.
And I just don't think in 2018 we can go
back in time.
It's interesting because that's one of
the ones where I've heard,
you know,
obviously there's a lot of mormons in
Utah,
but I hear a lot of people that talk
about the flyover states and they say
that,
you know,
a lot of the christian conservatives are
just voting on that no matter what.
So again,
it's,
it's a position where you as someone not
telling the conservative line on that,
that that's a serious uphill battle.
Yeah,
I think so.
But I think the lds church is
fundamentally a very compassionate
religion and I think that,
um,
it is compassion I think kind of can
mitigate that a little bit.
And it has actually the lds church,
its position,
rape,
incest,
life of the mother is actually a little
more progressive than some religions.
What do you make of,
uh,
how involved they've been in with gay
marriage?
It's not really talked about anymore.
It's the law of the land.
I get it.
It's sort of a boring topic for me at
some level.
Uh,
but they did have certain influence in
the whole national debate about over the
years.
it's interesting.
I think the lds church has come along
way in terms of basic rights,
but marriage is obviously a death,
a,
you know,
a defining line.
Um,
and in this era,
given we have marriage equality
nationally,
we'll see how they step up and you'll,
it's interesting,
there tend to be very,
uh,
open right now to more um,
lgbtq people involved in church services
and really sending a message of love thy
neighbor.
And I appreciate that.
Yeah.
Well,
it's interesting to me because it's like
people,
it's so easy to bash mormons and you see
it in comedy all the time.
And look,
broadway had the book of mormon.
I didn't even see the book of mormon
actually.
I heard it was great.
I would love to see it,
but it's like you can make that show
very easily.
There are certain books you're not
allowed to talk about that we'd never
make it on broadway.
So I always find like this need to bash
mormons all the time where it's like the
easy joke all the time.
It's like maybe they're actually not the
intolerant people because you have a
very easy time.
A joking.
Yeah.
Well you can.
I'm baptized lds and um,
I have a great relationship with my
friends who were still going to church
regularly and my family members who are.
And I think it's a,
I love any religion that lifts people up
and there are times where I disagree
with churches,
politics.
I would very much defend separation of
church and state and there are times
where I might raise an eyebrow and go,
wait a minute.
This seems like it's overstepping a
little bit,
but I do appreciate the lds churches,
incredible force for good in the youtube
community by um,
services and by creating a lot of
support within our salt lake city area
with,
um,
you know,
there's a food bank for members and they
make it open to people who are in
general need.
And I think there's a,
again,
at times I would have some differences
certainly,
but I support the role in that and the
commitment and anybody who chooses to
practice religion and it lives up their
lives.
That's a good thing.
Yeah.
So would you,
so because you're talking about all the
good things that the church does,
would you kick some of those social
services back to churches and synagogues
and mosques and everything else if,
if you had the power to do so?
Because to me I,
again,
as a small government guy,
that's what I would see at it sounds
like some of that's happened.
Well,
I think we do that.
I mean,
I worry about the tax bill now because
we're not going to get a ride off
anymore.
We're going to see how charitable people
really are,
you know,
who knows?
But we do that now.
I think we always,
I mean,
I love,
um,
the work that I'm able to do on the salt
lake county council when we have,
um,
a business leader step up and support
something a little bit of county dollars
as well.
And we have a public private
partnership.
So I think we see a lot of that now.
Could we take it further perhaps,
but I think we get that then get into,
you know,
incentives and benefits and what I want
to see in the community and what drives
me is problem solving and I don't think
the government is always the best
vehicle for solving those problems.
I mean,
we do have businesses,
individuals,
government,
the web of all of that to solve a
problem and do it creatively.
Um,
I enjoy doing that at the local level
and I think the federal level we can do
that better and do more.
What kind of support or not support are
you getting out of the dnc?
They got a whole slew of problems,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
so I just got the nomination
by the way,
just for the record a little bit after
when we're taping it,
so.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I just recently received the
nomination so I have not had anybody.
The doorbell rang and a big check from
the dance see by any means.
But um,
I've had conversations with the dscc.
I've been invited to tour the city here
in la and san francisco and seattle with
some of the us senators,
women.
Uh,
and that was a very educational for me
and a great benefit to have some time
with our three or four or five of our us
senators on the democratic side of the
aisle.
And so I think just the conversations
that connection,
I mean fundamentally I think the
democrats are trying to take back the
senate and we'll see how things play out
over the next six months or so in my
race.
And I'm hopeful that we'll get some
significant national support.
I think,
um,
I feel though my,
uh,
support should come from Utah and it is
and uh,
I just get up every day and see what I
can do to bring a check in and get low
dollar contributors to,
to get what they can and day to day and
we'll see what happens.
Yeah.
It's interesting to me because it seems
like you're really in a unique position
where you're,
you really seem to be fighting both
sides.
Maybe you don't want me to totally
presented that way,
but you're obviously fighting.
You're fighting the republican side as a
democrat in a,
in a,
in a red state,
but also what I mentioned earlier about
the,
it seems to me that the dnc and the
entire leadership from,
you know,
bernie and Elizabeth Warren and Keith
Ellison and tom perez,
like those guys seem way more left.
Some of the things you've talked about
here.
So I don't.
It's almost like why would they want to
support you?
Like your sort of against the stuff that
they're kind of.
No,
actually tom perez has visited a couple
of times.
He's pretty committed to playing in
every zip code and I think he's building
towards that.
I mean the republican party and the
democratic party have different
influences within its governance
structure.
So I haven't given up on the dnc paying
attention to you.
I think they've done a good job in the
past year and really engaging and
listening.
What's most important to me is that we
get to the point where I'm both parties
actually recognize that there cities and
there are communities and they're all
small small towns aside from,
you know,
los angeles,
New York city,
big cities in Florida,
etc.
Chicago were,
I mean,
there are people on the ground in my
state in need with,
you know,
the,
the need government to lift them up or
need some support in some way from,
um,
community based networks.
And I think that we have become both not
as,
and this isn't just the parties,
Washington and how we govern,
um,
you know,
a little too focused I think on urban
centers.
Do you think we're just too reliant on
government in general that the answer
always seemed for both parties at this
point?
I mean,
there's a couple outliers.
I think rand paul,
I always bring it up.
He's trying either you obviously have
disagreements with him on the,
on the amount of government,
but I see him as someone that's
earnestly trying to fight for what he
believes in and usually falls short
because the system doesn't allow it that
much.
Um,
but,
but that argument of how much
government,
we always,
the answer seems to always be more
unfortunately.
Well,
I think that we have to get back to some
pretty major changes back to reinventing
things because what I do when I look at
government and what's possible,
let's look at what we have on the table.
Unfortunately,
I learned in the nineties when I worked
for a congressman that things don't
happen quickly and I wish we could,
you know,
get out the etch a sketch and shake it
and start over.
Right.
But,
you know,
I,
and I think sometimes around paul and
others,
it's,
we have to accept that,
um,
we do have challenges with a lot of
people in need.
We do have income inequality and we have
to address those issues.
It would be nice,
I think to,
to Simply,
you know,
um,
have a smaller federal government,
but on the other hand,
what are we to do?
I think we would take a step back in
terms of progress for us all.
I think we all want the same thing.
So we want people to do well.
We want them to get up every day,
um,
have a,
have a step towards self sufficiency or
get out,
make a living,
not commit crime,
be happy.
I mean,
we all want the same thing.
The question is how do we get there?
Right?
So that is the question because the
latter part of that,
of course,
I believe all of those things and I
don't,
I really try not to impugn the motives
of the people that I disagree with in
general.
Not talking about you but just in
But to me the answer to,
to solve those problems would be just
the government keeps scaling back,
keep scaling back,
keeps coming back.
Hopefully private enterprise comes in
and you give people more self reliance
as opposed to creating a system that
they kinda can't move out of because I
think there's a lot of evidence for
that.
And that's the great debate and that's
the great.
Should we just have to look at,
you know,
I've worked for a little while at a
hospital that did an incredible amount
of ophthalmology research and I learned
a lot about research and development and
how the federal government works through
basic science and supports researchers
and I look at our innovation and our
nation and what we've done because we've
invested in that.
So when you talk about smaller
government and you have to say,
okay,
where and what is the next step by the
pure funding of science by the,
for the record,
either got a lot of books of scientists
who had been on the street.
We have to.
And then there's a lot of businesses
that receive benefits and support small
businesses on up.
Um,
you know,
we just allowed for a one point
$5,000,000,000,000
corporate tax cut without any
requirement that people return it to
wages and to growing companies.
And I see a lot of federal policies that
have overly supported business.
And I think especially now in this era
with that,
I mean I looked at and did a back of the
napkin on our own taxes.
I did quite a bit of assessment when the
tax bill came out at the end of the year
to see what it would do for a family of
four,
a family of six,
a larger Utah family and they're not.
Many of uS are.
We're going to get a big benefit from
that and now the mitt romney's and a few
others will and I think why in this era
we've got to find a way to,
if we are going to do tax reform,
tax simplification.
That was a principal we talked about
with her.
I'm like,
ah,
you know,
call her,
call your tax accountant because he or
she is gonna.
Make double now.
is there any
reason to believe that the government
can do these things?
Like,
like if you take just the general
stagnation we talked about in Washington
and most of the congressmen who do
nothing in the senators who've been
there forever and accomplish nothing or
it's just endless fighting or all that.
The idea that these people who often
have never created any jobs and it never
really made anything happen.
I mean,
I conclude bernie in this for sure.
The idea that they,
that they are the ones that are gonna,
figure out how to get the economy going
when it really comes from the people
that comes from the local businesses,
the small businesses,
etc.
Well,
congress should be listening to its
constituents and to it specialists and
that's why there's nothing that offended
me more than what happened with the
healthcare bill and the tax bill last
time with no debate.
I mean there were some efforts for to
have a bipartisan discussion around both
and one of the offenders was orrin hatch
who was trying to take and up down now
get outta here.
We gotta get home and that that's the
worst.
Oh,
government to me,
because we should have that.
We should have specialists in.
We should have a debate.
We shouldn't have lobbyists lined up and
we should actually have methods and
systems to do what I do on the county
council,
work with my colleagues,
bring specialists in,
listen to information and make good
decisions.
Yeah.
I
think you could probably draw a line
from the obamacare debate and how insane
that guide to everything that has led us
to where we are at now.
Even during that.
Yeah,
the wouldn't sit down and we're goIng
crazy the whole time and obama kept
saying in the reelection campaign,
we're going to do it on cspan.
It's going to be open door cspan and
it's like just the odd amount of
congressmen and senators that were
retiring in the middle of it after they
would make a decision or we need
something.
Just seemed
about the whole thing and let's go fix
it.
Let's go fix it and let's get back to
our real conversation and I,
I guess I feel maybe from going back
maybe a full circle now to talking about
my father again.
I think in the seventies,
in the eighties,
those things were more likely to happen.
The collegiality,
the discussion,
and one of the things that led to my
interest in this race was it like,
I am a reformer.
I,
I like you want to fix things.
So I want to go back and have a voice in
the system wherever I can find an ally
in,
in doing some of the things you're
suggesting that we get down.
We worked through these things.
Um,
but I actually think that,
uh,
if that's too big a deal initially,
at least that I can serve my state.
And that was my major interest in
running is I think that um,
we need a democrat from our delegation.
We have six ours.
Um,
we have six zero votes on everything and
there are a lot of people in my
community and in my state that are being
served by that.
Yeah.
I just quickly to reverse back to say,
we talked about before about,
and you were saying about being able to
sit down with people have crossed the
iron ore that you mentioned right before
we sat down that we have a mutual friend
in rick grinnell who I think as we're
taping this today,
we think he just left for Germany.
He was finally confirmed after over a
year of waiting to be the ambassador of
Germany.
So we're both thrilled.
You guys were were old roommates,
but he's a republican.
He's a trump supporting republican or a
democrat from Utah.
And guess what?
you guys are friends.
It's all good.
Yeah.
That does seem to be the thing that is
last.
These.
Yeah.
And I,
I just don't get that and I,
I have enough sense of my own
convictions that I'm not threatened by
going to dinner with republicans.
So are working with them on a county
council and I'll tell you,
there are times when the four democrats
look over at the other side of the aisle
and we're like,
we're done.
We're out.
But we have those conversations.
We work through our budget together.
We have some votes that are crossed
party lines and others that are,
they typically are,
you know,
some are some days.
Um,
and you know,
I think that's the reason that local
people or people who've worked at the
local level like myself,
need to get to congress.
We need to get more and more people who
get government to have worked in
government who solve problems and come
in with that commitment to,
to,
you know,
putting the time,
effort,
energy,
and to moving things forward.
Alright.
So let's talk about the race you were
involved.
Fair to say this is an uphill battle.
I think so a little bit.
Yeah.
Just say
just numbers.
It's,
it's a tough
one.
Okay.
So at the republican convention,
everyone thought,
I think,
or at least at the national level and
thought mitt romney was going to walk in
and clean this thing up.
Right.
The guy was the republican nominee for
president not too long ago and has all
the media behind him and all the money
and all that.
uh,
but my kennedy one,
I don't know much about Mike Kennedy.
So could you just briefly tell me a
little bit about him and then we'll
focus more on the romney.
Fascinating.
He's a legislator.
He is kind of himself as conservative,
more conservative than romney.
Romney sort of been all over the place.
So I don't know.
I really,
truly do not know mitt romney's
politics.
So my kennedy ran to the right of romney
and did pretty well at the convention.
Romney came in second,
so the two of them will go to a late
june primary.
Right.
So it was pretty close.
I think it was 51 slash 49.
So they will do a primary soon enough.
Yeah.
You would,
you'd have to claire,
60 percent at your convention to avoid
the primary,
which I did.
And so I,
yeah,
I've cleared my with 81 percent and then
there I've got it.
The primary now you worked for romney a
dead?
Yeah.
Tell me about that.
Um,
I worked for him.
He just said you don't know his
politics.
Well,
I thought I did at the time.
So I worked for the olympic games of
2002.
We had three or four of us who ran the
volunteer program,
recruitment retention training,
a 26,000
employees and volunteers on those games.
That made it a success and a.
Yeah.
So he was our chief executive and I was
senior staff and I saw quite a bit of
him and I was always a little bit
nervous when we had the quarterly budget
review with mitt romney was a big day.
What was that like a businessman right
as a now we went end with our budgets
and how to defend our programs and he'd
give us a up or down and I will say mit
did a good job of stabilizing the budget
and fundraising and that was,
he was good at.
That is a good,
good person to work for.
But when you say you don't know what his
politics are like,
what,
what does that mean?
Well,
he laughed right after the olympic
games,
um,
to Massachusetts to run for governor,
uh,
he had run against ted kennedy in
Massachusetts for the senate years
before.
So thIs was his,
um,
jump into political life again and he
won that race and I started to watch and
was interested because I knew him and it
seemed,
you know,
he was going in as a progressive
governor,
republican governor,
uh,
he signed an assault weapon ban.
He was pro choice and uh,
he got ruined in Massachusetts and then
not long after he ran for president was
defeated and then president and again,
and he ended up moving more and more and
more.
I'm going to the left,
but it was actually to the right,
right,
exactly what people would say.
People would say,
well,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Didn't he kind of start obamacare with
romney carried Massachusetts then was.
And then it
was also running.
Yeah,
it.
Yeah.
And then we have the history with trump
where he was,
um,
I think delivered all wooded would agree
the most scathing,
um,
speech against trump,
talking about his lack of values,
his inability to govern and was very
much in the amt.
Anybody but trump camp.
And then,
you know,
we saw the sit down when there was some
talk of secretary.
Yeah.
He did not look happy and then it seems
he's back with trump or.
Yeah.
So that's what we're left with right now
to kind of work through that in the
state.
Do you think when he had that moment,
I remember when he gave that press
conference,
it was late.
It looked like trump was gonna win no
matter what,
but he gave that press conference.
I read it more as and I think perhaps
the electorate did to that.
It was kinda like,
have you lost this thing?
So why would we listen to you?
Like the whole thing with trump was
about winning.
So it was like anyone that liked trump
wasn't going to be like,
oh,
he is making a couple of good points.
It's like,
no,
you were the loser.
They're trotting out the loser.
We tried it with mccain,
we tried it with romney,
we tried it with more centrist people.
Even though I actually think trump is
sort of interesting,
his own bizarre way,
but that's a whole other topic.
I'm like,
the idea of that just doesn't work
anymore.
It doesn't fly anymore.
Right,
exactly.
So I don't know.
I mean I look at romney and I feel like
I'm.
My biggest concern about a romney in the
senate is I think we just need somebody
from Utah fighting for Utah and I think
he's a national figure and I don't want,
I mean,
if romney does,
when the senate race,
people will notice now that many have
said,
well,
romney is going to get a chairmanship,
or what is that realistic?
I don't think so.
I meAn,
I can't imagine a republican senator
stepping aside for romney to come and
take,
you know,
It also gets to the heart of what you
think the problem is.
It's like you're trying to get a guy to
get in there for Utah and it's like,
oh,
congratulations.
He,
yes,
it's nice to get those powerful
positions,
but that's not the position now to help
your state the most.
Yeah.
So I'm from your tie.
I know you tie work in the state.
Uh,
I,
I love it.
I've lived there except for my time in
graduate school and my time working on
the hill and the nineties.
I've lived there my entire life.
I'm raising two children there.
I'm first generation your time,
uh,
and I recreate there.
I enjoy it.
I love the state.
Do,
do you think that feeling was what
caused him not to win the,
uh,
the convention?
Well,
it um,
because carpet bagging it kinda,
you know,
hillary was,
if we're going to use it was a guard
beggar.
She was from Arkansas and you know,
when he got in I did.
I didn't actually thought warren hatch
would run again because he loves the
senate and he doesn't know anything
else,
so I thought he might run again and um,
when he didn't,
it just didn't make sense to me knowing
that I'm at the sunset of his career,
he's had,
you know,
a very successful career financially and
got kids and grandkids and I figured,
hey,
at that point in my life I'd be like
looking to relax a little bit.
So it didn't seem to make sense.
And I think people when I worried a
little as a candidate like,
oh my goodness,
it was mitt romney,
am I even going to keep the lights on in
the campaign headquarters?
And what I found is that people are
asking that question.
Yeah.
How,
how long has he lived here?
People are even saying,
does he meet residency,
which he does.
He's been in Utah long enough now again.
Um,
but I,
I do think that there are people
wondering,
you know,
what is,
why,
why the mitt romney candidacy and that
may have been part of the reason that
this division occurred within the
republican party.
It's an interesting place as a democrat
because he's so successful as a
businessman and generally democrats want
attacks businessman more,
which is something you've already
alluded to here.
And yet at the same time you're also
saying that he ran the olympic thing and
the budget's pretty well.
So it's like there's some piece that
makes that a ton more.
I just don't want to give away more.
I mean,
going back to this tax bill,
if we had the one chance to reform,
I wanted it done differently,
but I do think that,
um,
you know,
it's,
we'll just see if the public,
if you tie aligns with mitt romney
candidacy.
I fundamentally believe in balance in my
state and that's what I've been fighting
for and I,
you know,
in my day life as a county elected,
I'll work on canyon protection or you
know,
advancing a development or protecting
our water and our air.
I'll do all of those things,
but I fundamentally am really fighting
as a democrat for balance and it because
I think it's really critical to,
um,
a less corrupt system,
a more even playing field.
All voices heard in the system.
We don't have a lot of women in politics
in Utah,
um,
when a lot of women in politics anywhere
including the us senate.
So I think getting more diversity,
more diverse voices in is really
important.
Those are the things I care quite a bit
about and we'll see if the,
my vision for the state resonates with
people versus romneys.
And I'm glad you mentioned that because
one of my biggest issues right now with
the democrats and with the left and
especially with the progressive than my
whole audience know this because I beat
this thing endlessly is identity
politics.
That you shouldn't be voting for a woman
just because she's a woman.
You shouldn't be voting for a black
person just because they're black or
white prison because they're white or
any of those ridiculous things.
When you talk about that sort of
diversity,
I think you sort of said it both ways.
They're like,
you want some more women,
which ended up itself.
Of course it's not a Bad thing,
but that one I think always gets lost in
that is diversity of thought and that's
what I'm more concerned about and I
don't see anyone talking about that on
a,
on the left anymore.
Well,
I don't know that I'm put jenny wilson,
democrat in x county council seat.
Take my colleague,
jim bradley.
I don't know that jim's better edison
elected than.
I wouldn't say he.
He or I are better because of our
gender,
but I do judge you on your ideas.
I mean that's the point,
right?
But I do think what is preventing when
women make up 50 percent of the
population,
women from being in the pipeline,
that's what we have to get out and we
have to figure out why we don't have
that.
I mean,
because ideally in a given body we would
see 50 slash 50.
now we are seeing a lot more women step
up in this era and we saw it in Utah and
they weren't all progressive.
Um,
we have a new mayor,
female of provo,
Utah,
which is the heart of a very,
very conservative conservative area.
The hummer,
brigham young university.
We have a woman at a small town not far
from salt lake city where I'm from,
to wIlla,
Utah.
And I think that's great,
but you hadn't seen that as often in the
state of Utah,
which is um,
mainly caucasian,
caucasian men typically over 60.
Right?
So I think that the voice of our
community is beyond that one segment.
So that's where I want to see people
say,
hey,
what is it that would get me to step up
to be considered within the system?
Do you think some of that is not just
that it's just like old crusty white men
doing it because I just think that's a,
I just think it's too sort,
sorta too easy to lay it on that,
that perhaps also that women are
interested in other things at some
level,
like the idea that we'd ever get it to
50 slash 50 or that it should be 50
slash 50.
That seems lIke very strange engineering
of things like if,
if these women are qualified and have
the right ideas and all that and it ends
up being 70 percent women,
30 percent men.
I think that's it.
I just don't care what it is other than
the ideas.
But there's something that when you,
when people talk about what we should,
you know,
it's like we should have this represent.
They represent this amount of the
population.
If you're talking about an ethnicity,
they should have this amount of
representation in politics that seems
incredibly dangerous and actually
prejudice to me.
Well,
I just think that you have to look at,
um,
barriers for participation.
I mean,
the good news is we're seeing a lot of
women have graduated from college now
for the first time,
so maybe that will change over time.
Right?
We're,
but I do think there's something to be
said for reform and change and um,
I think maybe we just disagree on this
point,
but I love to see more people reflecting
the percentages of our community serving
in government because I think I'm having
more voices for people who have lived a
certain way or have,
have some understanding of the,
um,
you know,
individual or kind of collective need
within a given community.
Yeah.
So that,
that part I think We probably have to
disagree.
Agree to disagree on.
I'm the sort of collective need,
hey,
like I want it to be very clear that I
don't,
not every woman in the state of Utah
needs to want to run for the us senate
for goodness sakes.
Right.
I value women who choose to raise her
children at home and have that option
within their family and that,
you know,
I,
my kids kind of tease me because I
missed sort of half a cook.
I'm not a very good and I looked at this
woman who I had are making like their
home and,
and,
and their,
their environment for their family,
just incredibly rich and interesting
through the commitment they make and
that way and I don't for a minute take
anything away from that because I
haven't taken a different path and I try
my best and we have an abandoned my
children by any means.
But yeah.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I,
I understand that for sure.
I mean my mom,
I have two siblings so we have three
kids in my family and my parents were
married over 40 years.
My mom worked before she had kids,
but then in all of our formative years
she didn't and my dad was the sole
breadwinner,
but then after my sister who's the
youngest got to a certain age,
my mom went back to work.
I look back on those years of my mom
being around and cook.
We know we always had dinner at 6:00
and all that stuff.
Like I look at that as great and yet
there's a certain segment of society
that kind of looks down on that and I
think that's so,
yeah,
and I think it's impressive and
wonderful if stats,
but I think that the point is that every
child,
he or she should grow up being whatever
they want to be and have,
you know,
have a right to the american dream.
And if in the american dream is staying
home and raising your kids and you're
able to do that financially,
then that's amazing.
If it's like me,
you know,
I want to make a difference in politics.
I've had that advantage in my life to be
given,
um,
you know,
a platform to get there.
And I think that's great.
So I would hope that for a young woman
who,
uh,
is high school or getting into college,
who aspires to do that,
that there won't be barriers in her way,
that she will be able to sit here with
you and a few years and you'll be able
to say,
I remember that jenny wilson,
she,
she was written for you cracking.
That's what it's all about.
Believing in equality of opportunity
that everyone has the exact same
opportunities.
I am completely on board with you.
Um,
anything else we should know about Utah?
We briefly tAlked about just the sort of
demographic
we have to come visit.
I told him,
I know I've never been to.
I can,
I can't believe that.
Like most people that I meet to have
been there a good skier to ski.
We have five national parks.
you can access our national parks
through vegas or Arizona or salt lake
city,
four or five hour drive south.
Um,
we have amazing national parks.
We have an agricultural area north up by
the Idaho border,
which is pretty amazing.
A lot of um,
somewhat barren land around the great
salt lake area.
Um,
you need to fly over the lake because
it's like,
you think you're on mars and there's
some water.
It looks very,
very different.
The landscape.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well,
it's been a pleasure talking to you.
I wish you luck.
As we said,
you've got an uphill battle here in a
state that is not the color that you are
because everyone's obsessed with this
silly,
a blue and red stuff.
But,
uh,
I'll be back on as a us senator.
That's what I'm talking about.
For more jenny's campaign,
check out wilson for senate backup.